dabei ist luca herzlich willkommen wir
heute zu einem neuen video auf seinem
kanal zusammen mit sandra die feature
das sei noch nicht das einmal der
badewanne sitzen und wir haben jedoch
eine flasche wasser und werden nun
gleich einen großen schluck wasser
trinken das hat unserem mund behalten
und juden
juni sitzt hinter der kamera und liest
flotte zuvor oder irgendwelche anderen
bis zur keine ahnung was irgendwas
worüber wir lachen müssen unter last ich
gucke jeder kennt ihn nicht lachen
zellen schalter ja wir können alles
[Musik]
das ist groß genau und versuchen was ist
groß grau und kann telefonieren telefax
ein paar sekunden später das heute hier
in server geschaut bekommt übrigens lvs
de luca sie hat diesen sehr leisten
verteidigt von sala und einer star wars
hochgeladen hat sich im nächsten video
von mir in unserem staat vertrauen
sollte dann verlinkt lesen gab eurem war
wie nennt man den flur eines diplom als
dealer wie nennt man einen dicken
schriftsteller kugelschreiber
[Musik]
was machen zwei wütende schafe sie
kriegen sich in die wolle
[Musik]
wo leben die meisten gespenster in
budapest
[Musik]
wie erkennt man eine ähnliche schokolade
wer schokolade
was stört auf dem fußballplatz und das
faultier irgendwelche schauen was haben
elektriker in der hose einen kurzen
wir werden gar nicht gut ich wohne sie
genau was sitzt im baum und weint eine
eule polizeikontrolle politischen kopf
hinhalten polizist haben sie erst ein
hoher autofahrer alles ausgetrunken
[Musik]
ich finde es irgendwas sache der sich
dann doch nicht das sollte ich mir das
auch enden wenn es euch gefallen und
ihre zwei hunde haben wollte lassen
daumen hoch unternehmer und ehemaligen
der einfachheit und abonnieren
[Musik]